[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so hello everyone I'm Kevin
O'Neill and I'm a visually impaired
front-end developer so in this talk I
wanted to go over some of the challenges
and some of the solutions that I came up
with during my five years of working in
the house working as a web developer and
so as I mentioned my name is Kevin no no
this is my twitter handle sorry it's a
little bit strange that's two
underscores twice so if you have any
questions or any suggestions please send
me a message that'll be great so I
worked at fast retailing it's a large
apparel company and based in Japan and
if you've been to Japan before you've
probably noticed a brand unique glow and
we have some stores in the US as well so
if you happen to come across any of
those stores please do check out some of
the items that we have for sale I'm
actually wearing one of them right now
so all right so one thing I wanted to
say was six years ago I was at
university and I had a lot of self
self-doubt and so for example I kind of
felt like perhaps I wasn't good enough
to kind of like be a developer or to
kind of like find a job just because of
some of the experiences that I went
through and what I wanted to say like
what this presentation is
please don't fall into that trap it's
easy to get to get discouraged and to
kind of not try to push yourself and
perhaps a lot of things can cause that I
wanted to ask everybody if you happen to
know somebody else who is able to
challenge or has a lot of other
difficulties or challenges please share
this story with them so right here I'm
just going to go through some of the
conditions that I have these are
actually there's three of them in total
and this is what I was born with
there is no corrective surgery for them
at this time so it's something that I'm
gonna have to just be stuck with until
there is something like that so the
first one is nystagmus which is a vision
condition in which makes the eyes eye
Federative uncontrolled movements so
sometimes like if you if you look at me
like I'm I don't probably go like in
random places or they'll be stuck in one
other complete different direction so
there's that the second one is myopia
which is nearsightedness and this is I
have quite of an extreme version of
nearsightedness that makes it quite
difficult thankfully I have these
glasses here that can extend my vision
quite a bit but mostly it's for if I'm
out and about or outside unfortunately
when it comes to like using a computer
screen or working I'm so used to not
having them on you don't tend to work
really well for those situations and the
last one I actually have difficult even
still pronouncing it maybe it's a blue
man phobia and it's it's also known as
like the lazy eye so those are the three
things that I have and we can actually
simulate this a little bit so I'm gonna
take off my glasses right now
and if you actually extend take out one
of your arms and extend it beyond that
point I can barely I can actually barely
see it's extremely burly if I'm looking
out right now I can it's all just a big
blob or a big blur and the second part
that my condition is that if you take
one hand and you place it over your eye
that's actually the field of vision that
I have like entirely so it's very narrow
and cut in half basically so about let's
say almost a year ago I ran into this
article by the Pew Research Center and I
found it pretty shocking and sad and as
you can see in the headline there's
quite a large digital divide between
people with disabilities or challenges
and and if you haven't heard of the term
like digital divide I'm sure you have
it's the gap between the people who have
access to technology or the internet and
those who don't so what I hope with this
presentation is in a way to close that
gap and I'll come back to this later on
a later point how I hope to achieve this
in the near future so this is one of the
this is the quote from the article that
kind of stood out for me
disabled Americans are about three times
as likely as those with a disability to
say they never go online 22% versus 8%
according to a Pew Research Center
survey conducted in the fall of 2016 so
that's quite a big gap
and so I'm gonna start with my story
here so I graduated from Cal State San
Marcos it's about a maybe a 25 20 25
minute drive from here actually and I
scheduled in December of 2012 and I
graduated with Visual and Performing
Arts
Technology degree so this is basically
like a graphic digital graphic design
and it took me about a year to find a
full-time job and part of this is
because like as you know when you're
trying to find your first job it can be
really really difficult just because
you're trying to stand out from other
applicants and getting your first job is
always the most difficult thing but in
my case since I was I'm raised in
Southern California I have these eye
conditions I am not legally allowed to
drive so often when I had an interview
and the employer might be asking
reasonably so of course like how would
you get to work and most of the times I
couldn't figure out like how to answer
that question and so I started looking
for places that would have a better
public transportation system something
like yeah
maybe in New York City or perhaps like
Portland Seattle just anything that
could kind of help me get to work on
Simon in during this timeframe I
actually got in contact with someone via
LinkedIn and I ended up in Tokyo Japan
we're just crying big ya jump I'm not
going to get too much into like the
cultural differences in this
presentation unfortunately but here I'm
just going to talk about like a little
bit of
like what I found when I've been living
there this is a disclaimer some of the
points or advice that I'm gonna give out
in this presentation might be just a
little bit tailored to just what how
that Japanese job market is or how my
experiences have been so this part is
about some of the advice that I would
give to myself like five years ago six
years ago when I was looking for a job
and one of those things is that if you
have if you're a really challenged or
you want to yeah I need some help I was
able to make a take advantage of the
California Department state of rehab if
you are from another state I'm sure that
there's another similar branch or
division and there's a lot of
educational and vocational programs that
they give out and help anyone disability
so I wanted to give a shout out and
wanted to thank the California
Department rehab for making this
possible
because without them I wouldn't be
speaking here in front of all of you
another thing so when I was first my
first job in my second job hi I should
did not ask for any help for my employer
to make my working situation a lot
easier to become more efficient so I'm
gonna show like an example of this this
is basically my setup in my previous
company a friend of mine took this photo
just to illustrate like how close I have
to be to the screen and it was great cuz
this is just like a monitor arm that
just attaches to your desk so this way I
can move around the monitor freely if I
need to and this is part of like why
I think it's important if you work like
for a good employer or someone that
really cares about you
they're willing to try to help you be a
lot more comfortable or be more
efficient at your job
and this is what allowed me to do that
so I wanted to thank my previous
employer my current employer for making
that happen
hopefully that starts happening a lot
more and that was just like one of the
most amazing things for me being able to
take advantage of that and now I want to
get into some of the tools that I was
able to use during my time as a
front-end developer and so my one of my
jobs
it was quite imperative to quite
important to keep the I say how
pixel-perfect designs so the designer
would of course I'm designed something
in Photoshop or illustrator and they
would send it to us the front-end
developer team and it needed to be like
pixel perfect like every pixel needed to
work or needed to be aligned in every in
a lot of browsers including Internet
Explorer so that was kind of tough
especially as someone who is nearsighted
and so with this part I wanted to tell
another story so it was quite late at
night maybe 8 p.m. or 9 p.m. and in
order to one of the designers would take
my web page that I was working on and
his design and he printed it out I'd
have no like physical media of this on
paper and wood came over to me and
started asking like hey this is how it
should actually look and he took started
taking out a ruler and kind of like
compared
how close like everything should be my
coworker right next to me actually said
hey so I have a better idea why don't
you just use this and this next slide is
a little bit like I heard your eyes a
bit so I'm going to just show it at
first for a couple of seconds and then
move back so that was great because it's
a little chrome extension that you can
just install and it will basically you
could set an image and it'll just lay it
on top of your website so you can kind
of like compare and see how close your
final web page is to design and not only
that but I was able to use it with some
of the accessibility tools that are
found in the Mac system preferences so
that was extremely helpful compared to
just dealing in the physical realm I
could just use the the great tools that
are already inside of the operating
system or Mac OS or Windows or whichever
one whichever OS you'd like to use and
that was like incredible so here's some
of the things that I like to set for
example and if you're using a Mac OS
then you can just go to the top left
there's the Apple icon you click on that
and go System Preferences and you click
on accessibility and the screen will pop
up and now there are different options
that you a lot of different options that
you can set and down here at the bottom
there's zoom command so there's two
different kinds of zooms that you can
use you can either have it set so it's
picture-in-picture as it's shown in here
and what that will do is it will create
a little frame inside of whenever you're
zooming in and there's the full screen
zoom which is doing that I actually
really like to use
and that was part of the tools that I
was able to use to help me out a lot
when I had to compare the designs with
the pixel-perfect extension and here's
some advanced options just in case so
it's yeah just as the arrow points on
the bottom right hand side and there's a
lot of other settings that I go through
and every time I set up a new computer I
make sure that all of these are set or
hopefully I can kind of sync them up in
a way so for example like in the chrome
settings which is what I usually use for
development
I sent the font size too large just
because it's a lot more helpful so I can
see and they even have page zooms that
you can adjust and see whatever you want
we can we're helpful and okay so we're
developers and we spend a lot of time in
editors and I've jumped around through a
bunch of different editors and so far
although I use Visual Studio code all
the time I love that I love that editor
a lot
I found the extensibility in Adam to be
really really really helpful I'm not
showing a previous slide but there's
lots of great editors that you could
make very extremely customizable and
here these are my basic settings and you
can ignore the bottom or the bottom up
bottom parts of it but yeah I usually
send everything to 22 or 24 size fonts
even for the integrated terminal and a
lot of different other applications just
because that's what I'm used to but
again everybody has their own challenges
and difficulties so it might be higher
might be lower and this is what it looks
like when I am editing
any my code okay so as I mentioned
earlier Adam is really great at
extending extending the user interface
and but I really hope to do in the
future is perhaps make a theme that for
example this city lights UI seeing that
can help perhaps people who have my
condition or other Pete other people who
are a really challenged and find ways to
make their time working a lot easier the
reason why I really like this theme is
because it puts the search right in the
front and pretty much the center of the
screen and you can kind of adjust it to
make it either the text bigger or
smaller this is what I hope I haven't
found a way to do it in Visual Studio
code yet but if you do happen to know
something like to make the search a lot
easier please please please do let me
know and then I can share that ok so
here's another thing that I found when
I've been working for about 5 years now
sometimes as we all do we need help with
what we're doing I need help with a
particular problem so I'll go to a
co-worker the thing is that when because
of my nearsightedness there's either two
options that we generally have or at
least that I first thought of is either
I get I have to get really close to
their screen or they would have to kind
of adjust their settings or something
like using the command or n+ tool to
kind of just like see zoom in the screen
but there is like a better way that I
found to do this and instead of
my coworker having to reset their
settings or go through their keyboard
shortcuts again and reset their
environments I actually found yes live
share to be extremely helpful for this
and Adam has teletype as well I haven't
been able to use it yet but I'm gonna
give it a try
soon and so these tools are actually
really helpful for me a lot perhaps at
first they were intended to of course be
more of like um maybe we're both if
you're working remotely with other
co-workers to kind of like do pair
programming but this these tools are
extremely helpful and I'm very thankful
that they're around and it's very easy
to get started on the menus them so what
can we do what can we all do to kind of
make accessibility better or make
improvements or start on these so this
is a great course by Google at I ready
to see you then it's Udacity and I
actually have started there's a couple
of months back just to learn more about
how what I can do what part that I can
do to kind of improve accessibility for
everyone so if you can please recommend
this to anybody that you know it's a
great course I believe it's a couple of
they have a couple of chapters maybe a
couple of hours and also I one of the
sister conferences Marci did a amazing
talk on improving improving
accessibility with empathy driven
development so if you can't please take
off a check out her je s coffee you talk
and workshops so at my previous company
I wanted we were quite a big team or
like quite a small team actually but
they're around 24 back-end developers
and two front-end developers including
me so I wanted to kind of show what
front-end development was like and so I
started these workshops these internal
workshops to kind of teach back-end
developers about front-end development
and I was I I found that they were they
found to be pretty successful and what I
wanted to do in the future is to start
an accessibility workshop perhaps here
back in the United States or even in
Japan to kind of encourage people to get
started and so that's about it for my
presentation thank you so much for
listening
[Applause]